the BBC is reporting that researchers
have found evidence of an existing body
of liquid water on the planet Mars so
this is not evidence that there someday
millions of years ago there was water
this is not evidence of ice but this is
evidence of liquid water on basically
what is being described as a lake
although some people are taking issue
with its description of being a lake
under Mars is south polar ice cap and it
is about 12 miles across it's estimated
to contain about a meter of water and it
is located one and a half kilometers
below an ice sheet so imagine you've got
a kilometer and a half of ice and then
below that a single meter of water and
scientists are being super clear that
this it really is a body of water it's
not meltwater that's stuck between rock
and ice it's a real bona fide body of
water what does this say about the
possibility of life on Mars
absolutely nothing scientists continue
to explain that the surface of Mars is
inhospitable to life as we know it
period and the search for possible life
now has to move beyond the surface and
to the subsurface where you would have
presumably protection from radiation you
would have pressure and temperature that
would make that would at least make it
slightly more likely than life on the
surface which would be extraordinarily
unlikely for any of the types of life
that we are already familiar with it's
also likely that the lake that was found
is very very salty because for water to
be liquid in such cold weather as cold
as what's on Mars the water probably
needs to have a ton of salt dissolved in
it so in case you were thinking of
drinking the water it would be
extraordinarily salty yeah I was
thinking about that like how much would
you pay for a bottle of Mars water yeah
I guess you can't but maybe if you have
a sore throat or something you could
gargle it it's not even clear we can get
access to this stuff because we would
sometime somehow have to bring or build
a means to drill through a kilometer and
a half of ice on Mars so it's unclear
what's next this is all becoming more
and more like Frank Herbert's classic
book dune
read that one Pat not that one do you
haven't read that one that's too bad
back to reality this is also interesting
because the more planets and moons that
we get information about the more it's
becoming clear that surface water is
pretty rare so on earth as you might
know we have surface water subsurface
water we've now found in a few spots so
on two of Jupiter's moons Europa and
Ganymede we found subsurface water on
and salad as' which is one of Saturn's
moons and now we found it on Mars so the
bigger picture that is kind of being
painted for us is that finding life
elsewhere might require being able to
dig down to where there's water and this
is also important because if we find an
exoplanet meaning a planet outside of
our solar system who knows where and we
identify that there's no surface water
that wouldn't necessarily tell us that
there's no life on the planet we would
actually have to look so very exciting
stuff and meanwhile on earth people
still dislike each other because they
were born with the wrong skin color
which really kind of puts it in
perspective in some way today's episode
of the show is made possible in part by
class central if you've ever wanted to
sit in on classes taught by world-class
professors at America's top universities
without actually having to attend those
universities and pay tuition class
central is the place to go it's a
comprehensive free search engine that
lets you find exactly the type of online
course you're looking for there are
courses from a ton of different
providers taught by some of the most
qualified professors in the country
thousands of courses to choose from many
of them totally free including courses
from Ivy League schools like Harvard
Yale Princeton other top schools like
Stanford and MIT you can search courses
by subject by University you can see
which courses are trending and you can
also rate and review courses and because
other users have already done this you
can see what other people have actually
said about the courses you're thinking
of taking I've been checking out a lot
of their courses on thinking both
critically and philosophically it's been
absolutely fascinating but they have
everything from political science to
philosophy economics math physics Comp
Sci business graphic design really
anything you can think of
and you can start taking classes taught
by top-tier professors from the best
universities in the u.s. right now by
going to class central.com slash Pakman
that's class - central slash PA que ma n
I've also put the link under this video
if you're watching on YouTube